يعني لماذا يتصنت هذا التطبيق على سين او
صاد الى هالدرجه هذا راح يغير من مستقبل
البشريه
جميل جدا
اي وداعات
بالضبط لانه هي مصلحه الجوال ومصلحه
التطبيقات ومصلحه الطرف التقني من الاجهزه
انه يحصل على قد ما يمكن من المنفعه مش من
الاسرار مو بالمعلومات ومن الصور قد ما
يحصل على المنفعه من صاحب هذا الجوال بحيث
انه شراء ونفس دائره الاستهلاك تستمر سواء
يقعد يقترح لنا مواقع خدمات منتجات وما
يقدر يقترح هذه الاشياء الا لما يعرف
اطبعك وعوايدك ولسه احنا لازم ناكد انه
احنا بالنسبه للاجهزه ارغام
هو اللي عم بتنصت علينا مش اشخاص هو
الالغريد بنفسه السيستم التطبيق نفسه بس
على كل حال فيصل كيف بنقدر نعرف بانه
الكاميرا او الميكروفون لتطبيق معين احنا
مش عم نستعمله حاليا في هاي اللحظه شغال
هل في هل في اشي يبين لنا اذا بتقدر تشرح
لنا خطوه بخطوه يعني
حلو اذا اي واحد من اجهزتكم الحين حاليا
على الايفون عندها اندرويد كمان واحد
موجود وفيه هنا ايفون كل اثنين موجوده
فاذا فتحتوا الكاميرا هتلاحظوا انه نفس
الكاميرا الحين صار يطلع لكم شعار فوق انه
الكاميرا شغاله وهذا الشعار اللي يطلع فوق
الخضراء
على
النقاط الصغيره سواء الحمراء او الخضراء
او البرتقاليه نقطه صغيره وهذا الامر على
الايفون وعلى كل اجهزه الاندرويد مع اخر
تحديثات فهنا نعرف انه الكاميرا يتم
الوصول لها ولو سويتوا نفس الشيء وفتحته
مسجل الصوت حتلاقي يطلع لكم لون ثاني من
نفس النقطه وهذا الامر مبني بين السوفت
وير بين التطبيق وبين البرمجيات وبين
الهاردوير وبين العتاد هذا الامر اخر
سنتين هو اريح شيء ولما نفتح اي تطبيق
ونلاقي طلع لنا احد هذه الثلاث نقاط نعرف
انه فيها في وصول لكاميرا او مايكروفون او
وصول الجهاز اللهم صل وسلم على محمد
الاساسيه فبالتالي لما ما نلاقي هذه
النقطه
نحاول يوصل
للمشكله اللي اصدرت على واتساب في هذه
التغريده اذا كان يطلب المايكروفون ما طلع
هذه الاضاءه اذا في برمجيه مو صحيحه وهذه
اللي من خلالها قدر ولكن احنا في اخر
سنتين في مامن باذن واحد احد مع اتباع
النهج الصحيح لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات